EU ministers meeting in the
competitiveness Council on Thursday and
Friday will hold a debate on three
important topics first they will discuss
how to foster industrial competitiveness
to create new jobs and growth
recognizing that Europe is still far
from the twenty percent target of
industry share in Europe's GDP by 2020
the Commission urged member states to
mainstream industrial competitiveness
across all relevant EU policy areas such
as environment energy trade or regional
policies the outcome of the discussion
will feed into the debate on industrial
competitiveness to take place at the
next spring EU summit following the
first report on progress towards the
implementation of the European research
area EU ministers are also expected to
outline the key elements that will
contribute to the completion of the
research area by 2014 by creating a
unified research area where researchers
scientific knowledge and technology can
circulate freely the idea is to
strengthen Member States is scientific
and technological capacities to increase
growth and jobs in the long run on space
matters ministers will discuss how to
better work with the european space
agency to support the global
competitiveness of the european space
industry and allow it to unleash its
full potential